Alors on a 1 question de Daddy qui nous dit,
si j'ai 18 ans après le 1ère mai,
est-ce que je pourrais quand-même voter aux élections
européennes ? Le 1ère mai,
c'est en théorie
la date
limite pour s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
et la réponse c'est oui, mais à certaines conditions.
Je t'explique,
si la date de ton 18e anniversaire
est après le huit/06,
malheureusement
tu ne pourras pas voter pour ce scrotin européen.
Mais si tu as atteint les 18 ans avant le neuf/06,
là tu pourras voter,
tu es même inscrit
automatiquement sur les listes électorales.
Enfin, à condition
d'avoir fait les démarches pour te faire recenser
l'année de tes 16 ans.
T'as oublié de faire ton recensement ? Je te rassure,
c'est pas trop tard,
tu peux encore t'inscrire
en ligne si ton 18e anniversaire est avant le 4 mai
et si c'est après,
tu peux le faire parcourir ou te déplacer à ta mairie.
Et tu peux retrouver toutes ces infos sur service
public pour les faire.
Et surtout n'oublie pas la date
pour te rendre dans ton bureau de vote,
les élections
européennes, ce sera le neuf/06
ou le huit/06 si tu vis en autre mer.